Guys, quite a day. Quite a day. I'm excited. I woke up really excited today. I went through audio security that was really surprising. What is that like? What is that like? Well, it was a lot of ear probing.
伙计们，真是忙碌的一天。真是忙碌的一天。我很兴奋。我今天醒来时真的非常兴奋。我经历了一次音频安检，真的很令人惊讶。那是什么感觉？那是什么感觉？嗯，就是耳朵被探测了很久。
So all the wax is out of both ears right now. Oh, finally. Yeah. I was testing my connection. Testing my connection. So all the wax is out of both of your arms right now. Oh, finally. I was testing my connection, testing my connection. But I feel like there's something really special coming. Well, it sounds like you guys are really cleaned up for today. What about you, Sean? Did you do anything?
所以现在两只耳朵里的耳垢都清理干净了。哦，终于好了。是的。我刚才在测试我的连接。测试我的连接。所以现在你两只耳朵里的耳垢都清理干净了。哦，终于好了。我刚才在测试我的连接，测试我的连接。但我感觉有什么特别的事情要发生了。嗯，听起来你们今天都清理得很干净。你呢，肖恩？你做了什么吗？
No, I got up early because I was nervous about today. Well, you have a good right to be. It's a big, big day for us. Because of our listeners, because we're a place that really important folks like the Tim Walls campaign think that this might be a worthy stop. So thank you to you listeners. You guys made this happen and we are really excited
没有，我起得很早，因为我对今天感到紧张。嗯，你有充分的理由紧张。这对我们来说是非常重要的一天。因为我们的听众，因为我们是一个像蒂姆·沃尔兹竞选团队这样重要的人物认为值得一来的地方。所以感谢你们，听众们。是你们促成了这一切，我们真的非常兴奋
to talk to our next guest. So get ready. We also want to say, I know that a lot of people, you know, come and listen to Smarlist because it's a great place to kind of get away from all the noise and stuff. And giggle and snag. Yeah, but JB, you were talking,
能采访我们的下一位嘉宾。所以准备好了。我们还想说，我知道很多人，你知道，来听《SmartLess》是因为这是一个远离所有噪音和琐事的好地方。还能咯咯笑和闲聊。是的，但是JB，你刚才在说，
like this is also a really good time to remind people that they need to. Yeah, that they don't need to vote, but they should vote, they could vote. We happen to have our own opinions that become pretty apparent and evident just because we're on the side of common sense, but just vote.
这也是提醒人们他们需要去投票的好时机。是的，他们不是非得投票，但他们应该投票，他们可以投票。我们恰好有自己的观点，而且因为我们站在常识这一边，这些观点变得相当明显和显而易见，但总之去投票吧。
A lot of people hurt or killed or whatever, trying to secure that right for all of us. Let's just go use it. We only get to do it once every few years. And I think you're right. And again, it can't be said enough, which is even if you don't agree with us, that's okay, but still get out and vote.
很多人为了确保我们所有人的这项权利而受伤或牺牲。让我们去行使它吧。我们每几年才有一次机会。我想你是对的。再说一次，怎么强调都不为过，即使你不同意我们的观点，那也没关系，但还是要出去投票。
It's still important. We all have that right. And I respect your right to do it. And you should respect mine. Did Jay, when you said common sense, do you think I have a lot of common sense? It's an all new smart list. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
这依然很重要。我们都有这项权利。我尊重你行使它的权利。你也应该尊重我的。杰伊，当你提到常识时，你觉得我有很多常识吗？这是一个全新的《SmartLess》。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. By the way, dinner was really good last night. Was it? Yeah, it was really good. What'd we have? Oh, I know what we had, burgers, right? Burgers, yeah. Burgers and...
Smart。Less。顺便说一句，昨晚的晚餐非常好。是吗？是的，非常好。我们吃了什么？哦，我知道我们吃了什么，汉堡，对吧？汉堡，是的。汉堡和……
Did you bring a dessert, Sean? I brought a ton of dessert. He did. Did you really? Listen, I'm not even kidding. I brought brownies, rice krispie treats, banana muffins. I'm sorry, I just want to stop and say, I thought for you, rice krispie cakes were for breakfast.
你带甜点了吗，肖恩？我带了大量的甜点。他确实带了。你真的带了吗？听着，我没开玩笑。我带了布朗尼、米饼、香蕉松饼。抱歉，我只是想打断一下说，我以为对你来说，米饼是早餐。
It's breakfast. That was a breakfast. Well, this is true. Well, that's the great thing about them. You can eat them any time of the day. That is the great thing about them. Isn't that? Thank time of the day. That is the great thing about them. Isn't that? Thank you. Yeah.
那是早餐。那是一顿早餐。嗯，这是真的。嗯，这就是它们最棒的地方。你可以在一天中的任何时候吃它们。这确实是它们最棒的地方。不是吗？谢谢。是的。
So, Will, you tried each one of those things. I did not have any. Oh, how about that? He's pretty disciplined about the no sugar right now. Yes, and then I told you, Will, by the time I get home, I will have a bowl of ice cream, and I did. Oh my God.
所以，威尔，你每样都尝了一点。我什么都没吃。哦，那怎么样？他现在对不吃糖这件事非常有纪律。是的，然后我告诉过你，威尔，等我到家时，我会吃一碗冰淇淋，我确实吃了。天哪。
And I said to Sean, we were talking about sleep, which has been a recurring theme for us. And he was talking about his poor sleep hygiene and waking up or not being able to go to bed. And I said, what are you having at night? He goes, nothing, this'll be you. This'll be my meal. And I go, and when I get home,
我对肖恩说，我们当时在谈论睡眠，这已经成为我们的一个反复出现的话题。他当时在谈论他糟糕的睡眠卫生，以及醒来或无法入睡的问题。我说，你晚上吃什么？他说，没什么，这就是我的晚餐。我说，等我到家时，
I mean, I might have some ice cream. I go, well, there it is. Anyway, let's get to our guest. Yeah, whose guest is this? I've not heard this so. It's America's guest. It's America's guest. There are only a few times, probably less than five,
我是说，我可能会吃点冰淇淋。我说，好吧，就是这样。总之，让我们请出我们的嘉宾。是的，这是谁的嘉宾？我还没听说过。这是美国的嘉宾。这是美国的嘉宾。只有几次，可能不到五次，
I don't know, on this show, this thing that we do, where the guest, all three of us know who the guest is because they're a big freaking deal. And today is one of those shows. And I speak for all three of us when I say that this is a huge honor to have him come speak with us for a bit. He's many things, all of which we'll get into shortly
我不知道，在这个节目里，我们做的这件事，嘉宾是谁我们三个人都知道，因为他们是大人物。今天就是其中之一。我代表我们三个人说，能请他来和我们聊一会儿，我们感到非常荣幸。他有很多身份，我们很快都会谈到，
from the Army National Guard to teacher to congressman to governor to so many other things. But to me, he's the quintessential all-American dad I never had. Oh, and he's also a coach, something else I could probably use in my life. Currently running to be the next vice president of the United States of America, please welcome Tim Walz.
从陆军国民警卫队到教师，到国会议员，到州长，还有很多其他身份。但对我来说，他是我从未拥有过的典型的全美式老爸。哦，他还是个教练，这也是我生活中可能需要的东西。目前正在竞选下一任美国副总统，请欢迎蒂姆·沃尔兹。
There he is. Tim. Hi, Tim. Hello there. Well, hang on. How do you like to be addressed? Just Tim. Just Tim. Just Tim. Hello there. Well, hang on. How do you like to be addressed? Just Tim. Just Tim.
他来了。蒂姆。嗨，蒂姆。你好。等等。你喜欢别人怎么称呼你？叫蒂姆就行。叫蒂姆就行。叫蒂姆就行。你好。等等。你喜欢别人怎么称呼你？叫蒂姆就行。叫蒂姆就行。
Just Tim. I stick to that. I will say this though. We did a trade mission to London and the hello governor stuff, I just lived on it for the entire week. The entire week. Hello Governor. Hello Governor.
叫蒂姆就行。我就坚持这样。不过我要说的是。我们去伦敦进行了一次贸易代表团访问，那些“你好，州长”之类的称呼，我整个星期都沉浸在其中。整个星期。你好，州长。你好，州长。
And it wasn't ironic. It was like real. That's hysterical. It was better. Yeah, no, Tim is great. Tim, it was like real. Yes, I know, that's hysterical. It was better, yeah, no, Tim is great. Tim, I want to get, because I saw Will last night, Jay, we missed you, you were at the Dodger game. I know, I know, I'm sorry.
而且那不是讽刺。那是真心的。太搞笑了。那更好。是的，不，蒂姆很棒。蒂姆，那是真心的。是的，我知道，太搞笑了。那更好，是的，不，蒂姆很棒。蒂姆，我想问，因为我昨晚见到威尔了，杰伊，我们想念你，你在看道奇队的比赛。我知道，我知道，我很抱歉。
That's okay. I should have skipped the Dodger game, they got waxed. No, but we were talking about sleep, I always talk about sleep with these guys because I've always had trouble. And then I'm like, you got thrown into this campaign. Obviously late in the game. I can't wait to hear where this is going.
没关系。我本该跳过道奇队的比赛，他们输惨了。不，但我们当时在谈论睡眠，我总是和这些家伙谈论睡眠，因为我一直有睡眠问题。然后我就想，你被卷入了这场竞选。显然是在比赛后期。我迫不及待想听听这会往哪儿发展。
No, I want to know, it's a very dumb, Sean smartless question. Is your sleep hygiene, like you go 20, it seems like you go 24 hours a day just going for this, and then this, and this. You have to do all the work to do. Sean's worried, Tim, that you're not getting enough sleep. That's what I'm worried about, that's my question.
不，我想知道，这是一个非常愚蠢的《SmartLess》问题。你的睡眠卫生是怎样的，你似乎每天24小时都在为这个竞选奔波，然后是这个，然后是那个。你必须做所有的工作。肖恩很担心，蒂姆，你睡眠不足。这就是我担心的，这就是我的问题。
When do the naps happen? How do you get, where the energy comes from? Well, you know, the good thing is, old men need less sleep or whatever, I guess. Look, I do not sleep that much. I've been using this saying, it's kind of my catch thing. I said, we'll sleep when we're dead. And I had a woman come up to me and goes,
什么时候小睡？你是怎么做到的，能量从哪儿来？嗯，你知道，好消息是，老年人需要的睡眠更少，或者随便什么，我想。听着，我睡得不多。我一直在用这句话，这算是我的口头禅。我说，我们死后自然会睡。然后有个女士走过来对我说，
you're taking this too literally. You look like hell, man. She meant it well, but no, I'm trying. I'm always fascinated by that, by schedule. Just the schedule's full all day, every day. It's amazing. Yeah, well, it's a privilege to do it, but you're right. My daughter keeps me on this.
你把这句话理解得太字面了。你看上去糟透了，伙计。她是好意，但不，我在努力。我总是对那个时间表很着迷。每天整天日程都排满了。太神奇了。是的，嗯，能做这件事是一种荣幸，但你是对的。我女儿让我保持这个状态。
She got one of these rings, you know, monitor your sleep, whatever she needs, I need one of those. But I think that will just tell me what I already know. I'm not getting any sleep. That's all it'll say. Tim, let me just say this. I haven't done the ring, but I've done will just tell me what I already know. I'm not getting any sleep. That's all it'll say. Tim, let me just say this. I haven't done the ring, but I've done the Apple Watch thing, whatever.
她买了这些戒指中的一个，你知道，监测你的睡眠，无论她需要什么，我也需要一个。但我认为那只会告诉我我已经知道的事情。我根本没睡够。那只会显示这些。蒂姆，让我说一句。我没用过那个戒指，但我用过苹果手表之类的东西。
And we'll say- The great Apple Watch. Sorry, the great Apple Watch. Jason wants a free Apple Watch. No, it's just because they're listening. Oh, don't worry, he already got it. I think it's really good stuff. I think these Apple folks are onto something.
然后我们会说——伟大的苹果手表。抱歉，伟大的苹果手表。杰森想要一块免费的苹果手表。不，只是因为他们在听。哦，别担心，他已经拿到了。我觉得这东西真的很好。我觉得这些苹果公司的人确实搞出了点名堂。
It's great work. Tim, by the way, we should be called, not smartly, we should be called shameless. And if there's any product out there you've got your eye on it, just mention it and we'll have them send it to you. That new 16 Pro guys, it's really working. So, what I was gonna say about that,
这是伟大的工作。蒂姆，顺便说一句，我们应该叫《Shameless》（无耻）而不是《SmartLess》。如果有任何你关注的产品，提一下，我们会让他们寄给你。那款新的16 Pro，伙计们，真的很好用。所以，关于那个我想说的是，
watch those sleep tracking things. I got into it for a while. And I think your daughter's right because you go like, okay, we'll work on I, but then at the end of the day, what ends up happening is you start feeling bad. So I wake up and I go, I think I did okay, and then I'm like, oh my God, I only got three hours of REM, and then I got sleep panic.
注意那些睡眠追踪器。我有一段时间沉迷于此。我觉得你女儿是对的，因为你会想，好吧，我们会努力，但到最后，结果是你开始感觉很糟糕。所以我醒来时会想，我觉得我做得还可以，然后我就想，天哪，我只有三个小时的快速眼动睡眠，然后我就陷入了睡眠恐慌。
See what I did? Yeah, yeah. It is just the thing, I think seeing, the one thing about this is there is an is an end state if you will on November 5th, so you just kind of put your mind into it and say look this there will be a time when this ends You know really that's probably not true. You think things get calm after the fifth It's the trick I play myself yeah team is good. I I'm surprisingly And you wouldn't know it by looking at me, I'm a pretty dedicated runner.
看我做了什么？是的，是的。这确实是这样，我认为看到这一点，关于这件事的一点是，有一个终点，如果你愿意的话，在11月5日，所以你只是把你的心思投入进去，说看，总有一天这会结束。你知道，那可能不是真的。你认为5号之后事情会平静下来吗？这是我对自己玩的把戏，是的，蒂姆很好。我，令人惊讶的是，你从我的外表看不出来，我是一个相当专注的跑步者。
I run about five times a week. Oh, that's great. How far do you go? I go a 5K usually between three and five miles. And I'm like, for an old guy, I'm kind of freakishly fast. Nine minute miles, little less or whatever. Wow. And people are like, oh my God,
我一周跑大约五次。哦，那太棒了。你跑多远？我通常跑5公里，在三到五英里之间。而且我像，对于一个老家伙来说，我跑得快得离谱。九分钟一英里，或者稍微快点。哇。人们会说，天哪，
that's a world record for a man your age. But now, Tim, now you can't, well, which is, and you know, people are like, oh my God, that's a world record for a man your age. That's good. But now, Tim, now you can't, well, as governor, you had security detail. Were you running with, or were you on a treadmill? I do a treadmill quite a bit of the time, but you have to get outside, and my team knows, like, wherever, or anywhere, and actually, you know,
那是你这个年龄的人的世界纪录。但现在，蒂姆，现在你不能，嗯，也就是，你知道，人们会说，天哪，那是你这个年龄的人的世界纪录。那很好。但现在，蒂姆，现在你不能，嗯，作为州长，你有安保人员。你是和他们一起跑，还是在跑步机上跑？我大部分时间都在跑步机上跑，但你必须到户外去，我的团队知道，无论在哪里，实际上，你知道，
here a while back, after we finished that debate, the next morning, I got to run in Central Park. And it was awesome. We ran that reservoir route. Of course it was just stunning. And I'm still truly the small town guy enough, I have not spent much time in New York. It just blows me away when I'm there.
前阵子，在那场辩论结束后，第二天早上，我得以在中央公园跑步。那太棒了。我们跑了那个水库路线。当然，那真是令人惊叹。我仍然是一个足够的小镇男孩，我没有在纽约花太多时间。当我在那里时，它真的让我大开眼界。
And that morning, so many great people, it was kind of good for the psyche. Oh, good job, Governor. And I'm like, oh, thank goodness. And they're, of course, super surprised I'm running too, so it was like a double positive. So, well. I like the idea of you running in Central Park,
那天早上，那么多很棒的人，这对心理很有好处。哦，干得好，州长。我就想，哦，谢天谢地。当然，他们也非常惊讶我也在跑步，所以这就像双重积极。所以，嗯。我喜欢你在中央公园跑步的想法，
looking around, and really, because you haven't been there a lot, taking it in, twirling around, not unlike Mary Tyler Moore did in Minneapolis. And then Mary Tyler Moore. That is surprisingly close to how it was. I think we'll make it after all. Now, Tim, when you're running, do you have AirPods in?
四处张望，真的，因为你没去过那里很多次，沉浸其中，旋转，就像玛丽·泰勒·摩尔在明尼阿波利斯做的那样。然后是玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。这和当时的情况惊人地相似。我想我们最终会成功的。现在，蒂姆，当你跑步时，你戴着AirPods吗？
Are you listening to music? Are you listening to... Rarely, sometimes. I'm kind of zen on that. I got into it, you know, and then I got into the Garmin watch, and then I got in on the timing and, you know, how fast my miles were. Oh, look, he's looking for freebie now. But I kind of let that go and I kind of run by feel trying to get into it and I do think there's something and especially like when I'm in Minneapolis, I got a state trooper but just it's pretty calm.
你在听音乐吗？你在听……很少，有时。我在那方面比较禅。我沉迷于此，你知道，然后我买了Garmin手表，然后我开始关注时间，你知道，我的配速有多快。哦，看，他现在在找免费赠品了。但我有点放下了那个，我凭感觉跑，试图进入状态，我确实认为有些东西，特别是在明尼阿波利斯时，我有一个州警，但它相当平静。
They're running behind or whatever. Folks who run leave their, I'm convinced of this, dog folks and runners, they leave politics out of it because they know it's your time. So it's really refreshing that people talk to you like a runner, not like you're the governor or something. So like, you know, looking good or whatever. Do you have a favorite subject that you do like to talk
他们在后面跑或者什么的。我确信这一点，养狗的人和跑步者，他们把政治排除在外，因为他们知道这是你的时间。所以人们像对待跑步者一样和你交谈，而不是像对待州长那样，这真的很令人耳目一新。所以，你知道，看起来不错之类的。你有什么喜欢谈论的、不是政治的话题吗？
about that is not politics? Like, are you a sport, I know you're a sports guy, but like you love talking about the Vikings or the Cornhuskers or whatever it is, or reality television, or what do you like to talk about that's kind of nice and silly? Yeah, I think cars. I grew up at a time, you guys are a little younger than me,
比如，你是个体育迷，我知道，但你喜欢谈论维京人队或玉米剥皮者队之类的，或者真人秀电视，或者你喜欢谈论什么比较轻松有趣的话题？是的，我想是汽车。我成长的那个时代，你们比我年轻一点，
this whole cars thing, we were much more into it. The Pixar movie? I remember. I'm kidding. I apologize for him. So, but I just think like classic cars. I've never really owned that many, but you know the cars you have. I watched the cars I used for him. So, but I just think like classic cars, I've never really owned that many, but you know the cars you have.
整个汽车热潮，我们对它投入得多得多。皮克斯电影？我记得。我在开玩笑。我替他道歉。所以，但我只是觉得像经典汽车。我从来没有真正拥有过那么多，但你知道你拥有的那些车。我看着我以前拥有的车，你知道我在高中时有一辆漂亮的科迈罗，你知道，当时，然后我把它换成了一辆本田思域。现在你看着这些拍卖节目，我就想，该死，那辆车现在值8万美元了。而我把它换成了一辆值两千块的本田思域。完全正确。
I watched the cars I used to own, you know I grew up in high school and had a beautiful Camaro, you know, at the time, and then I traded it for a Honda Civic. And now you watch these auction shows and I'm like, damn it, that car's worth $80,000 now. And I traded it for a Honda Civic worth two grand. Exactly.
我有一辆，我妈给了我这个，我在高中时又踢又叫，我说，求求你，我能有一辆车吗。她给了我一辆200美元的车，上面全是锈。我的朋友雷娜，你知道雷娜，这些家伙认识雷娜，她叫它“油脂闪电”，她说，你今天开着“油脂闪电”去学校。
I had, my mom gave me this, like, I kicked and screamed in high school, I'm like, please can I just have a car. She brought me like a $200 car, it had like rust all over it. And my friend Reyna, you know Reyna, these guys know Reyna, she called it Grease Lightning, and she's like, you're taking Grease Lightning
现在，你真的喜欢内燃机的声音，还是你喜欢内燃机的声音，或者你喜欢……电动引擎的声音，电动车的清洁动力。看，整个光谱，整个光谱。我当时在凤凰城，是一个州长活动之类的，那里有人在展示他们的商品，Lucid的人也在那里。是的。哦，是的，Lucid的人也在那里，带着他们有史以来最快的量产车。你把任何兰博基尼放在那里，这东西，
to school today. Now what about, are you really into the sound of a combustion engine, or are you into the sound of a combustion engine or are you are you in into the? Sound of an electric engine the clean power of an electric Look whole spectrum the whole spectrum of this I I was in I was in Phoenix for It was a governor's event or whatever and there's folks there displaying their wares and the lucid folks were there. Yeah. Oh, yeah and the Lucid folks were there with their fastest production car ever. You put any Lamborghini out there, this thing,
它就像在宇宙飞船里一样。哦，这东西四分之一英里加速只要1.8秒。我是说，零到60英里加速。简直不可思议。这就像一个全新的世界。我还没拥有过全电动的，但它们很迷人。所以，是的。我很兴奋。
and it was like inside a spaceship. Oh, this thing's like 1.8 seconds in the quarter. I mean, it's zero to 60. It's unbelievable. And it's like a whole new world. And I have never yet owned a fully electric, but they're fascinating. So, yeah. I'm so excited. and I have never yet owned a fully electric, but they are fascinating.
是的，它们是最棒的。我喜欢它。我非常兴奋，现在每个汽车品牌都有全电动汽车，我不想对马斯克先生投下不必要的阴影，但我得告诉你，他的政治立场是，我处理了我的特斯拉。我觉得我开着一辆贴着特朗普贴纸的车到处走，所以它没了，我现在正在享受……
Yeah, they're the best. I love it. I'm so excited that every single car brand now has a fully electric car, and I don't want to throw undue shade towards Mr. Musk, but I got to tell you, his politics is, I got rid of my Tesla. I feel like I'm driving around a Trump sticker
你是指那个加密货币，我叫它加密卡车。总之。好吧，这是我的东西。这是对我而言。我说，我的东西，我的珍贵财产是我拥有它很长时间了。我有一辆79年的国际收割机。
with that car, so it's gone, and I'm now enjoying a Trump sticker with that car. So it's gone and I'm now enjoying. You mean the crypto, I call it the crypto truck. It's just, anyway. Well, here's my thing. This is for me. And I said, my thing, my prize possession is that I've had it for a long time. I got a 79 international harvester.
你知道，他们过去常把这些东西送人。Scout，Scout 2。就是那个。看，你们听到了吗？这些东西。但是的，这些东西是，你过去买拖拉机时，他们会附送一辆Scout给你。它是最初的SUV。
You know, they used to give these things away. Scout, Scout 2. There you go. Look, you guys hear that? These things. But yeah, these things are, you used to get it if you bought a tractor, they threw in the Scout for you. It was an original SUV.
是的，那是70年代末。所以我的那辆是在他们倒闭之前不久的。那是1979年。它们是SUV的前身，但重点是。40年前的10月底是他们关闭的时候。它们是在印第安纳州韦恩堡制造的。所以今年那个日期，他们宣布新的Scout回归，完全电动。
Yeah, there was a, back in the late 70s. So mine was right before they went out of business. It was 1979. They were the precursors of SUVs, but here's the deal. 40 years ago at the end of October is when they closed. They were made in Fort Wayne, Indiana. So on that date this year, they're announcing the new Scout bringing it back fully electric.
得了吧。不是开玩笑吧。所以国际收割机Scout，那个著名的名字，名字回来了，大众汽车买下了它。所以他们正在推出那个东西。所以我的意思是，这就是我谈论的东西。而且是的，是汽车的东西，因为名字回来了，大众汽车买下了它。所以他们正在推出那个东西。这就是我谈论的东西，而且是汽车的东西。你得去参加戴克斯·夏普德的播客，因为他会和你聊三天关于汽车的话题。我喜欢这些家伙，那些非常聪明的人告诉我怎么做。
Come on. No kidding. So an international harvester Scout, that famous name, name is back, Volkswagen bought it. And so they're launching that thing. So I mean, that's the stuff I talk about. And yeah, it's the car stuff, because it's back, Volkswagen bought it. And so they're launching that thing. That's the stuff I talk about, and it's the car stuff. You've got to go do Dax Shepard's podcast, because he'll talk to you for three days about cars. I love these guys, and the guys who are so smart tell me how to do it.
看，我只是在边缘修补。这些人是可以更换变速箱的。我喜欢那样。我说等我做完这个，我要回到社区大学学习车身修理。那种你可以修理自己的车辆、可以装上新的四分之一面板、可以给它喷漆的成就感。肖恩，你在高中学过车身修理，对吧？
Look, I'm Tinker on the edges. These are guys that can replace a transmission. I love that. I said when I get done with this, I'm going to go back to community college and learn body work. Just a sense of accomplishment that you can fix your own vehicle, you can put on a new quarter panel, you can paint it. Sean, you took body work in high school, right?
像很多补灰之类的东西。是的。如果你在路边抛锚了，你是那种可以掀开引擎盖，往里面看，四处看看，然后发现，哦，问题就在那里的那种人吗？是的，有些可以，有些不行。但看，在这些新车上，
Like a lot of reiki and stuff like that. Yeah. If you broke down on the side of the road, are you one of those guys that can just pop the hood and look under there and kind of look around and see like, oh, there's the problem. Yeah, some of it, some of it I can't. But look, on these new ones,
我甚至不知道怎么打开引擎盖。我会说，我听起来像个老家伙，这些新奇的东西。但以前你可以修理的那些车，我的孩子们，这会让他们大吃一惊，比如我们能修理的一些东西，比如我的车过热了。我说，哦，是恒温器。
I don't even know how to open the hood. I will say that. I sound like I'm the old guy, these newfangled. But the cars that you used to be able to do, my kids, it would blow their mind like some of the stuff we could fix, like my vehicle's overheating. I said, oh, it's the thermostat.
然后你会向他们展示如何把它取出来，放进沸水里，弹出恒温器。我正想说，孩子们不再知道那些东西了。他们不知道，而且有些，杰森如果爆胎了会给他的经纪人打电话。是的，所以。你知道。所以，我的意思是，这就是事实。
And you'd show them how to take it out, put it in boiling water, pop the thermostat. I was going to say, kids don't know that stuff anymore. They don't, and there's some, Jason calls his agent if he gets a flat tire. Yeah, so. You know. So, I mean, and that's the truth.
我的意思是，你需要知道关于这个家伙的真相。但是，我的意思是，他是个好莱坞精英，自由派精英。但是，但是。我站在斯顿斯顿大道的拐角处。但老实说，如果我，比如如果我的车开始发出“嘟嘟嘟嘟”的声音，说一个好莱坞精英，自由派精英。但老实说，如果我的车开始发出声音，我会靠边停车，然后想，我不知道发生了什么。是的，我完全不知道，是的，一样。
I mean, you need to know the truth about this guy. But, I mean, he's a Hollywood elitist, liberal elitist. But, but. I'm on the corner of Stunston Boulevard. But honestly, if me, like if my car starts to go do-do-do-do, and say a Hollywood elitist, liberal elitist. But honestly, if my car starts to go, I'm pulling over and I'm like, I don't know what's going on. Yeah, I have no idea, yeah, same.
让你感到无力。我说，我想，乔和我的孩子们，有些你可以尝试修理的东西，我喜欢做。现在看，我们都知道那也非常、非常危险，因为我有时不知道，我开始把东西拆开，然后你就想，
Makes you feel powerless. I said, I think, Joe and my kids, some of these things that you can try and repair, I like doing it. Now look, we all know that's also very, very dangerous because I don't know sometimes and I start taking stuff apart and then you're like,
嗯，这里有六个多余的螺丝，完全不知道它们要去哪儿。我身上确实有那种情况。所以。是的，当然。现在说到你的孩子们，当有人叫你“沃尔兹”而不是“沃尔斯”时，他们中哪一个，或者你，或者你妻子最生气？
well, here's six extra screws and there's no idea where they're going. There's a bit of that with me. So. Yeah, for sure. Now speaking of your kids, which one of them or you or your wife gets most pissed off when somebody calls you Waltz instead of Walls?
是的。是的，我女儿可能最生气。是的，现在又是一波新的了，对吧？是的。人们有什么毛病？沃尔斯。是的，没有T。是的，没有T。
Yeah. Yeah, my daughter probably. Yeah, it's a whole new wave of it now, right? Yeah. Like what are people's problems? Walls. Yeah, there's no tea. Yeah, there's no tea.
这看起来很简单，但说句公道话，可能当我们从德国移民过来时，他们可能去掉了T。嗯，这是最后一波了。就像你现在不可能比现在更出名了。所以南方的每个人终于明白了。我保证。
It seems pretty easy that, but you know, in all fairness, probably when we immigrated from Germany, they probably dropped the tea. Well, this is the last wave of it. Like you cannot get more famous than you are now. So everyone in the South finally got it. I guarantee it.
是的，告诉我那个，我知道这就像一个标准答案，但我真的想知道当你接到卡玛拉的电话时，那种感觉和反应是什么样的。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。嗯，你知道那个故事，以我典型的风格，我错过了第一个电话。当然，你错过了？嗯，我以为那就像一个汽车保修电话打进来了，
Yes, tell me what that, I know this is like a stock answer, but I really want to know what that feeling was like and the reaction when you got the call from Kamala. I mean, that was so wild. Well, you know the story, in typical me fashion, I missed the first one. Sure, you did? Well, I thought it was like, you was like a car warranty call coming in,
所以我没接。而且真的，没人知道。就像这是她的决定，那个周二早上，没人知道，然后我接到了另一个电话，说：“接起你该死的电话，然后回拨。”你的保修可能快到期了。这太令人不知所措了，这是一个不可思议的荣幸，
so I didn't take it. And truly, no one knew. Like this was her decision, and that Tuesday morning, no one knew, and then I got another call and said, "'Pick up your damn phone,' and then called back." Your warranty may be expiring. It was overwhelming, it was an incredible privilege,
但我听到你们在谈论，我听了泰德·丹森和伍迪·哈里森关于冒名顶替综合症的那段话。相信我，当美国副总统打电话给你说你和我一起竞选时，那种感觉会沉淀下来。所以我——挺酷的，是的，很快。很快。
but I heard you guys talking, and I listened to the Ted Danson Woody Harrelson piece about imposter syndrome. Just trust me, when the Vice President of the United States calls you and said you're on the ticket with me, it sinks in. So I- Pretty cool, yeah, fast. Fast.
你是否允许自己真正想象并开始建立一个可能的愿望清单，列出当你获胜时你想要被赋予权力的东西？嗯，这是一个，我认为这只是你心理健康中对事情进行分类的问题。仍然专注于我们面前的最后冲刺，仍然在考虑那个。
Have you allowed yourself to really imagine and start to build a possible wish list of things that you would like to be given the reins to when you guys win? Well, this is one, and I think it's just your mental health of compartmentalizing things. Still focused on this final stretch that's ahead of us, still thinking about that.
我相信副总统会对此做出她的决定。我说，我和她谈话时不是在面试工作。我说，使用我的技能组合。如果你需要把我扔到奥马哈去赢得一张选票，就把我送到那里。这正是我会帮忙的。而且我认为她，这对我来说感觉非常正确。她谈论一个来自奥克兰的孩子，
I trust the vice president will make her decision on that. I said, I wasn't interviewing for a job when I talked to her. I said, use my skillsets. If you need to plunk me in Omaha to win one vote, send me there. Just what I would have helped. And I think she, and it feels really right to me. She talks about a kid from Oakland,
一个来自内布拉斯加的孩子，中产阶级的孩子，某种互补的东西。我们过着不同的生活，但我们有相同的价值观。所以我假设她会知道。我的热情是孩子、教学和教育。就是这样。我们马上回来。
a kid from Nebraska, middle class kids, kind of complimentary things. We've lived different lives, but we have the same values. So I would assume she would know. middle-class kids, kind of complementary things. We've lived different lives, but we have the same values. So I would assume she would know. My passion is kids and teaching and education. And that's it. We'll be right back.
现在回到节目。我们最近刚和某人谈论过这个想法，当你处于这样的位置并接到副总统的电话说，嘿，你入选了，你会感到紧张。这可能让你感到紧张。但我怀疑，当这样的事情发生时，这几乎是一件你甚至无法梦想的事情，至少我肯定做不到。
And now back to the show. We were just talking with somebody recently about this idea of getting nervous when you're putting it in a position like this and getting a call from the vice president saying, hey, you're on the ticket. Makes you probably makes you feel nervous. But I wonder if when something like this happens, it's almost like a thing that you can't even dream about, at least certainly I couldn't.
所以这几乎就像你甚至无法感到紧张，因为它远远超出了你的……我可以对我想做的事情感到紧张，但如果有什么新的事情到来。不，那是一个伟大的，那是一个伟大的类比。我的意思是，想想那天，这是一个周二早上，我们接到了电话，20分钟内我的生活改变了。我说我在家里管我自己的该死的事，突然间它就爆发了。
So it's almost like you can't get even nervous because it's so far beyond what you, I can get nervous about things that I think about doing, but if something comes that's new. No, that's a great, that's a great analogy. I mean, think of that day, this was a Tuesday morning, we got the call, within 20 minutes my life changed. I said I'm minding my own damn business at home and all of a sudden it blows up.
应该指出的是，蒂姆，我拒绝了。我是第一个电话，然后蒂姆是第二个电话。哦，肖恩。我只是，我们很诚实。但他们涌进来，你周围有所有这些人，他们为你打包衣服，告诉你，你进去坐上一架私人飞机，这是，我从来没有坐过私人飞机来做这件事，
It should be noted, Tim, I did turn it down. I was the first call and then Tim was the second call. Oh, Sean. I'm just, we're being honest. But they sweep in, you've got all these folks around you, they pack your clothes for you and tell you, you go in and get on a private plane, which is, I've never flown on a private plane to do this,
所以他们把你飞到费城。那很有趣，因为，嘿，杰森从来没有……是的。我希望。我一直在等它。嗯，他们把你带到费城。那很有趣，因为，戴夫，杰森从来没有……是的。我希望。我一直在等它。嗯，他们把你带到费城，然后我也，我告诉他们当他们面试我时，我说，
so they fly you to Philadelphia. That's funny, cause, hey, Jason's never not. Yeah. I wish. I was waiting for it. Well, they take you to Philadelphia. That's funny, cause, Dave, Jason's never not. Yeah. I wish. I was waiting for it. Well, they take you to Philadelphia, and then I also, and I told them when they were interviewing me, I said,
看，我从来没有用提词器做过演讲。我说话，而且它，看，它有它的问题，我告诉过他们。你会得到大约90%的好东西，然后你会得到10%你需要清理的东西。那就是我，因为那就是我说话的方式。但他们把我送到那里，他们把我放在一个大学更衣室的后面，他们模拟了
look, I've never given a speech off a teleprompter. I speak and it, look, it has its problems, and I told them that. You'll get about 90% good, and then you'll get 10% stuff you'll have to clean up. That's me, cause that's how I talk. But they sent me there, they put me in the back of a college locker room, and they had mocked up
我大约一小时后要去的舞台，并把演讲稿放在提词器上。所以我练习了一点，然后我站在费城的那个门口，大约12,000到15,000人在等着看副总统的这个公告。她和她站在幕布外面，她就像，你知道，嗯，把这个搞定。
the stage I was going to go on in about an hour, and put the speech on the teleprompter. And so I practiced it a little bit, and then I'm standing at that door in Philadelphia, like 12, 15,000 people waiting to see the vice president in this announcement. She and her standing out on the curtain, and she's like, you know, well, get this right.
所以它打开了，这就是当时的情况。但不，你是对的。我认为你的分析是对的。它太大了，以至于无法为此感到紧张。我没有时间去想它。当你出来时，你看起来并不紧张，他太棒了，感觉就像，我们开始吧。老实说，蒂姆，真的感觉就像，我们开始吧。
And so it opened up and that's what it was. But no, you're right. I think your analysis is right. It was just too big to get nervous about it. I didn't have time to think about it. You didn't seem, when you came out, he was so terrific and it felt like, here we go. Honestly, Tim, it really felt like, here we go.
我们正在进入一个新时代，感谢上帝，蒂姆是那个人，蒂姆在这里。当然，还有很多其他伟大的候选人。那种真实性，那种纯粹的快乐、幸福和荣幸，你一定能感觉到，它传达了出来，这真是太令人耳目一新了。对你来说，保持那种脚踏实地的个性很难吗，你显然有这种个性，
We are entering into a new age, and thank God Tim is the guy, and Tim is here. And there are a lot of other great candidates, for sure. And that authenticity, and that genuine joy, and happiness, and privilege that you must be feeling, it comes through, and it's just so damn refreshing. Was it hard for you to maintain that down to earth personality, which you clearly have,
当你进入政治圈时，大多数同事要么必须，要么已经学会了变得过于圆滑和油腔滑调。看到那么多那样的同事，你感到沮丧吗？这只是，你太令人耳目一新了。嗯，这是一种不同的方法。我总是这么说，我从来没有，
when you got into politics, where most of your fellow politicians either have to be or have learned to be overly polished and slick. Is it disheartening for you to be around so many colleagues that are like that? It's just, you're so refreshing. Well, it's a different approach. And I always say this, that I never,
说实话，我从来没想过竞选公职。在此之前我有一整段生活，教学、国民警卫队、在我的社区里，诸如此类的事情。但我认为我的生活让我准备得很好。所以我采取的方法是，看，你在我的社区里必须相当有自我意识。这不是授予你的特殊东西。你的工作是为人民服务。我试着采取的方法是，
and honest to God, I never thought about running for office. I have a whole life before this, teaching, National Guard, in my community, and things like that. But I think my life prepared me well. And so I approach like, look, you have got to be pretty self-aware in my community and things like that. This isn't a special thing that you've been granted. Your job is to work for people. And I try and approach it like,
我被雇来在学校教孩子，所以我需要尽我所能。你知道，我可以公开的。我被雇来做代表。我非常自豪我非常两党。我，你知道，这种我们无法解决问题的想法。我的员工，我们总是有一句格言，你知道，如果事实与我们的意识形态相冲突，我们就改变我们的意识形态。
I was hired to teach kids in school, so I need to do my best job. You know, that I can publicize. And I've been hired to be a representative. And I took great pride that I was very bipartisan. I, you know, this idea that we can't figure things out. My staff, we always had a saying that, you know, if the facts dispute our ideology, we change our ideology.
就这么简单。你不是和它结婚了。所以很多时候我在争论中没有意识形态的立场。这只是事实显示的结果。而且我认为尝试像解决问题一样处理这些事情，你和人们一起工作，你试图尽你所能，我会第一个承认这真的很有挑战性
It's that simple. You're not married to it. So a lot of times I don't have an ideological dog in a fight. It's just what the facts show. And I think trying to approach these things like problem solving, you're working with people, you're trying to do your best, I'll be the first to admit it has been really challenging
和唐纳德·特朗普在一起。你知道，我在2016年赢得了国会竞选。唐纳德·特朗普在我的选区以两位数的优势获胜，接近20%。你知道，我在2016年赢得了国会竞选。唐纳德·特朗普在我的选区以两位数的优势获胜，接近20%。所以成千上万的人在那次选举中投票给了唐纳德·特朗普和我，那只是几年前的事。现在今天还会是真的吗？可能不会，他们继续……但我认为尝试专注于工作是什么，
with Donald Trump. You know, I won a congressional race in 2016. Donald Trump won my district by double digits, nearly 20%. You know, I won a congressional race in 2016. Donald Trump won my district by double digits, nearly 20%. So thousands of people voted for Donald Trump and me on that, that was only a few years ago. Now would that be true today? Probably not, they've continued to. But I think trying to focus on what the job is,
那是一种谦逊，而不是你的全部身份。我看着这些人试图紧紧抓住这些工作之类的东西，就像它是全部一样。如果人们不想让我做，他们就不会做，但我告诉你，这是我们可以做的。是的。你知道，蒂姆，首先，我希望，祝贺，我真的希望你的竞选，正如你所说，
that it's a humbleness and it's not your whole identity. I watch these folks try and hang on to these jobs and things like that, like it's everything. If the folks don't want me to do it, they won't do it, but I'm telling you, here's what we can do. Yeah. You know, Tim, first of all, I hope, and congrats, and I really do hope that your run, as you say,
你是一名高中老师和教练，你没有任何政治抱负。我希望你决定这样做能激励其他像你一样的人，他们是社区的领导者，他们不寻求致富，他们不寻求除了服务之外的任何东西。我希望这能激励其他人做你所做的事情，
you were a high school teacher and a coach and you had no sort of political aspirations. I hope that you deciding to do it inspires other people like you, who are leaders in their community and who aren't looking to enrich themselves, who aren't looking for anything other than to serve. I hope that inspires other people to do what you've done,
因为这就是我们需要的东西。我每天见到数百人。谁应该？他们不会，他们不会，因为钱，因为他们害怕如果他们参与进来会发生什么。因为社交媒体之类的事情，他们的生活会被颠覆等等。
because that's what we need. I meet hundreds every day. Who should? They won't, they won't though, because of the money and because of what they're afraid will happen if they get into it. And because of things like social media and their lives will get upended and all that.
还有安全。是的，我们在那场辩论中谈到了这件事的压倒性。他们开车带我穿过时代广场，看到我的照片在大屏幕上，所以有人说，你看上去很紧张。不是开玩笑，我坐在那里对此感到抓狂。但我向上帝发誓，在事情直播之前，
And security. Yeah, we were speaking of the overwhelming thing on this back during that debate. They drove me through Times Square to see my picture up on those big screens and so somebody said, you look nervous. No kidding, I'm sitting there freaking out on this thing. But I'm honest to God, before things went live,
我站在那里，我想，这个国家有3.45亿人，而我和这个家伙，这简直不对劲。这是真的，我的意思是，这有点令人不知所措，但那消除了我的冒名顶替综合症，说，看，我知道什么是对的，我知道我是谁，我试图做正确的事。我只是回到你的价值观，如果你离开。
I'm standing there and I'm like, there's 345 million people in this country and it's me and this dude, that is just not right. And it's true, I mean, it's kind of overwhelming, but that kind of got rid of my imposter syndrome and said, look, I know that I know what's right, I know who I am, I'm trying to be right. I just go back to your values and if you leave.
所以威尔的观点是这个，我确实希望人们这样做。我确实希望他们走出去，因为我们需要他们。我们需要好人。所以我正想说，然后你，当你谈论让像唐纳德·特朗普这样的人在你的选区获得两位数的支持率时，你认为是什么让人们说服自己他会
So Will's point is this, that I do hope people do this. I do hope they get out there because we need them. We need good people. So I was gonna say, and then you, what do you think it was when you talk about having a guy like Donald Trump getting double digits in your district, what do you think it was that allowed people to convince themselves that that he would
是……你知道，当我看到他们，你知道，这些顶级工会决定说，嗯，我们不知道今年是否能支持一位真正的候选人，因为他们担心他们的成员，工会成员。想象一下，想要支持唐纳德·特朗普的工会成员，那个想什么都不做、除了无视他们之外什么都没有的家伙。这太令人震惊了。我相信我可以对此得到一百万条评论。我们社交页面上的某个人，人们会说，嘿，如果你不在，
be you know when I see that they you know these top unions are deciding like well we don't know if we can endorse an actual candidate this year because they're worried about their membership union union member. Imagine this union members who want to support Donald Trump the guy who wants to do nothing, who has nothing but disregard for them. It's staggering. And I'm sure I could get a million comments back on this. Somebody on one of our social pages, people would say, hey, if you aren't at,
你不知道你在说什么。首先，我做过很多真正的工作，所以我回敬你。但同时，这是一个对美国家庭没有任何尊重、对勤劳的人没有任何尊重、对任何事情都没有尊重的家伙，他破坏工会的速度比你能想象的要快。那么，他们能够愚弄这些人到底是因为什么？是的。而普通工会成员，有一件事，
you don't know what you're talking about. First of all, I have had lots of real jobs, so I say right back at you. But also, this is a guy who doesn't have any regard for the American family, doesn't have any regard for hardworking people, doesn't have any regard, would bust a union as quicker than you can imagine. So what is it about that, that they've been able to fool these people? Yeah. And rank and file union members, one thing,
看，工会的领导层，那比我做的更政治化。他们必须在他们的事情上掩盖自己的屁股。威尔，我对这件事和你一样感到沮丧。但我确实想的一件事，你好奇发生了什么。我首先想到的是，我的选民没有问题。
look, the leadership in unions, that's more political than what I'm doing. They have to cover their butt on their things. And I'm as frustrated as you are on this, Will. But the one thing I do think about, you wonder what happened. The first thing I think of, there's not something wrong with my constituents.
这些是试图去工作和做事情的好人。就像《纽约时报》每隔几周派人去采访酒吧里的一个人，弄清楚农村美国发生了什么。这些是我的家人。我住在那里。我确实认为其中一件事，我作为老师总是这么说，
These are good people trying to go to work and do things. And like the New York Times sends somebody out every few weeks to interview a guy at a bar and figure out what happened to rural America. These are my family. I've lived there. I do think one of the things, I always said this as a teacher,
如果我进行考试或什么的，大多数学生表现不好，可能和我有一点关系，我没有传达清楚吗？所以我认为其中一些是我们如何传达这个信息。我不认为那是全部的责任。当然，唐纳德·特朗普是操纵大师，是新媒体看起来是什么样的大师。
if I would give an exam or something and a majority of students would not do well, probably had a little something to do with me in there was I not getting it across. And so I think some of it is how we message this. I don't think that's the full blame on it. Certainly Donald Trump is a master of manipulation, a master of what new media look like.
但我确实认为有一些方法，我们没有做什么来吸引那些普通成员？看，我是工会成员，我想。这就是我所做的。我得到了很多工会的支持，但我知道有一些普通成员。所以他们不是单一的，这不是他们唯一的问题，但我这么说，威尔，我在这方面和你一样，
But I do think there's some ways, is what are we not doing to appeal to those rank? Look, I'm a union member, I think. That's what I did. And I get a lot of union support, but I know there's some rank and file members. And so they're not monolithic, it's not their only issue, but I say this, and I'm kind of with you on this, Will,
其余的，如果你不在工会里，你就不必担心所有那些剩下的东西，因为你的工资不会那么高，你不会有养老金，你可能没有医疗保险。你最好专注于重要的事情，做好你自己的事。所以他们在分散注意力方面做得很好。
the rest of it is you don't have to worry about all the rest of that stuff if you're not in a union because you're not going to get paid as well, you're not going to have a pension, you may not have healthcare. You better focus on the things that matter, stay in your lane. And so they've done a good job of distracting on things
至于剩下的部分，如果你没有加入工会，就不必担心那些琐事，因为你的薪水不会那么高，没有养老金，可能也没有医疗保险。你最好专注于重要的事情，做好自己的本职工作。所以他们成功地在这些事情上转移了注意力。
that are the cultural war stuff rather than the bread and butter. Right, right. Well, you know, it seems like if those folks were slightly more sort of curious or discerning when it comes to news, information, facts, maybe they wouldn't make that decision and maybe they would be more prone to vote for you guys instead of him.
那些是文化战争的东西，而不是民生问题。对，没错。嗯，你知道，如果那些人对新闻、信息和事实稍微多一点好奇心或辨别力，也许他们就不会做出那样的决定，也许他们会更倾向于投票给你们而不是他。
Can you as a teacher attract that back or attribute that to something that we're not doing right in schools? To sort of, and you know, because I just feel like it's just common sense to me, it seems like there's a clear choice for everyone in this country. If you just want to take just preserving democracy alone, who to vote for, but all these, these smaller issues, it does seem like pretty easy. If you just look a little bit further than, you know, Fox News or whatever, you would see, oh, all the facts are on the side of
作为一名教师，你能把这种现象归因于我们在学校里做得不够好的地方吗？因为我觉得这对我来说是常识，对这个国家的每个人来说，选择似乎很明确。如果你只是想保护民主，该投给谁，但所有这些较小的问题，看起来确实很容易。如果你稍微看得远一点，而不是只看福克斯新闻之类的，你就会发现，哦，事实都站在
going this direction instead of that direction. And maybe does it start at schools? Well, this may be, but this is where I think Vice President Harris is focusing really rightly. This idea of middle class doesn't sound like anything so groundbreaking, but this idea of housing and down payment assistance, this idea of cost now, this idea of middle class doesn't sound like anything so groundbreaking, but this idea of housing and down payment assistance, this idea of cost now, this idea of child tax credit, because the one thing I will say, Jason, on this is,
这一边，而不是那一边。这是否始于学校？嗯，这有可能，但我认为哈里斯副总统正是在这一点上非常正确地聚焦。这种中产阶级的理念听起来并不那么开创性，但这种住房和首付援助的理念，这种成本的理念，这种儿童税收抵免的理念，因为有一件事我要说，杰森，关于这一点，
is that these guys on the other side have created an economy which many of the people you're talking about are busting their ass just to get by. They don't have time to spend a lot on this. They're trying to figure out how to afford childcare. They're trying to figure out how to make things work. They see inflationary prices go up, and we may say, look, inflation is higher
就是对方阵营创造了一种经济，你提到的许多人为了维持生计都在拼命工作。他们没有时间花太多精力在这上面。他们正在努力弄清楚如何负担得起托儿费用。他们正在努力弄清楚如何让生活运转下去。他们看到通货膨胀导致价格上涨，我们可能会说，看，通货膨胀在
everywhere else in the world. They don't care about that, because that's impacting with them. They hear a guy like JD Vance say, egg prices went up. Yeah, because of bird flu. They don't care about bird flu, they just know egg prices went up. So I do think there's a part,
世界其他地方更高。他们不在乎那个，因为那正在影响他们。他们听到像万斯这样的人说，鸡蛋价格上涨了。是的，因为禽流感。他们不在乎禽流感，他们只知道鸡蛋价格上涨了。所以我确实认为有一部分，
certainly discerning on media is something my wife used to teach a course on modern media, language and logic, trying to think through that. But I think part of it is these guys have, as we're saying on this, they've shifted wealth to the point where the wealth gap is staggering. When you see it in a graphic, people can't believe how truly bad it is. And what's stuck on that is a whole bunch of people trying to get through their lives and Donald Trump has told them, you know where to put the blame rather than that So I'd gap the gap the wealth gap the wealth gap has never been is never been bigger and never and I remember saying this Ten twenty years ago how that gap was widening one and now we're at this place
当然，媒体辨别力是我妻子过去教的一门关于现代媒体、语言和逻辑的课程，试图思考这些问题。但我认为部分原因是这些人，正如我们所说，他们已经转移了财富，以至于贫富差距令人震惊。当你看到图表时，人们简直不敢相信它有多么糟糕。而困在其中的是一大群试图度过生活的人，唐纳德·特朗普告诉他们，你知道该把责任归咎于谁，而不是……所以贫富差距，贫富差距从来没有像现在这样大，我记得十二十年前说过这个差距是如何扩大的，而现在我们处于这个境地。
And if if people think for one minute that Donald Trump and JD Vance give two craps about the middle class, they're looking to do tax cut to the richest Americans, to these billionaires to give tax cuts to those. When the people who need the tax cuts are the people right in the middle who drive this country, who have made this country what it is. When you do that, Minnesota is listed as, you know, the Republicans always say it's a high tax data. We're home to many Fortune 500 companies,
如果人们有一分钟认为唐纳德·特朗普和万斯关心中产阶级，那他们就错了，他们寻求的是给最富有的美国人，给这些亿万富翁减税。而真正需要减税的是那些处于中间、推动这个国家发展、使这个国家成为今天这样的人。当你这样做时，明尼苏达州被列为，你知道，共和党人总是说这是一个高税收州。我们是许多财富500强公司的所在地，
high concentration, but we have what's rated as the fairest tax system. It's a progressive tax system. If you don't make as much, you don't pay as much. If you make more, you pay more. Look what ends up happening that. Top five business state, top three place to raise kids, top place for healthcare, longest longevity.
高度集中，但我们拥有被评为最公平的税收制度。这是一个累进税制。如果你赚得不多，你付得就不多。如果你赚得多，你付得就多。看看结果如何。前五名的商业州，前三名的育儿地，医疗保健的首选地，最长寿的地区。
Look, we're not perfect, I mean, and it's cold as hell here in the winter, so there's things that happen. But I thought you controlled the weather according to Marjorie Taylor Greene. Yeah, if we did, it would not be 40 below up here. Right. But you're right, this idea of making the case
看，我们并不完美，我的意思是，冬天这里冷得要命，所以总会发生一些事情。但我以为根据玛乔丽·泰勒·格林的说法，你控制了天气。是的，如果我们能控制，这里就不会是零下40度了。对。但你是对的，这种向人们证明
to people that this works, and look, this isn't class, they said you're engaging class warfare, they already won the war almost on that, the guy's on the other side. But this is about sense of fairness and it's stunning to me that I thought one of the, my killer lines in this that the middle class would say, do you think it's fair Donald Trump doesn't pay tax?
这行得通的理念，看，这不是阶级，他们说你在进行阶级斗争，对方阵营的人几乎已经在这一点上赢得了战争。但这关乎公平感，令我震惊的是，我以为我在其中的一个杀手锏是中产阶级会说，你认为唐纳德·特朗普不纳税公平吗？
That doesn't seem fair. And a lot of people are like, well, he's successful, he knows how to work the system. That's disappointing to me. Work the system. I imagine, put it this way, if my dad gave me $400 million, I'd be a hell of a lot richer than Donald Trump is. I guarantee you would.
这看起来不公平。很多人会说，嗯，他很成功，他知道如何利用体制。这让我很失望。利用体制。我想，换个说法，如果我爸爸给了我4亿美元，我会比唐纳德·特朗普富有得多。我保证你会的。
I know. Absolutely. You could have put it in a CD. 80%. Exactly, I might touch it. What do you think would be the best way or easiest way to penetrate that bubble that they all seem to be firmly inside of as far as giving them the information that they need
我知道。绝对的。你可以把它存进定期存款。80%。没错，我可能会动它。你认为渗透他们似乎坚定身处其中的那个泡沫，就向他们提供他们需要的信息并可能左右他们的投票，最好或最简单的方法是什么？
and could sway their vote. Like, do you literally have to go to town hall meetings in some of these deep red districts? Does it mean being on Fox News a little bit more often? Like, how do you get to them? Yeah, I think that's right. We have folks, Pete Buttigieg goes on Fox News quite a bit. He's one of our best spokespeople.
比如，你真的必须去这些深红选区的市政厅会议吗？这意味着要更频繁地出现在福克斯新闻上吗？比如，你如何接触到他们？是的，我认为那是对的。我们有伙伴，皮特·布蒂吉格经常上福克斯新闻。他是我们最好的发言人之一。
You've been on it too. Yeah, and go on and just talk to folks, because I don't think we can assume that all of them are not there. Like the Vice President making that case, getting out there, going to places. We're going into some of these pretty red areas, and this is another one of the vice president's things
你也上过。是的，去和人们交谈，因为我不认为我们可以假设他们都不在那里。比如副总统提出那个观点，走出去，去到那些地方。我们正在进入一些相当红的地区，这是副总统的另一件事，
that I think when they feel this and people can see it, we're getting off a bus tour in rural Pennsylvania and one side of the street has our supporters and the other side of the street's not. I said they always make it easy for us, they're all in the same hat so we can see and we know who they are. But she didn't blink and it wasn't performance art.
我认为当他们感受到这一点，人们能看到它时，我们在宾夕法尼亚州农村结束了一次巴士巡游，街道的一边是我们的支持者，另一边不是。我说他们总是让我们很容易辨认，他们都戴着同样的帽子，所以我们可以看到并知道他们是谁。但她没有眨眼，那不是表演艺术。
The only people there were her husband and my wife and I. And she said, Tim, don't ever forget, we work just as hard for folks on this side of the street as on the other side of the street. You start to see some of the results of that and we're seeing it in Minnesota. It's pretty hard. Like the vice president's advocating
那里只有她的丈夫、我和我妻子。她说，蒂姆，永远不要忘记，我们为街道这一边的人民工作，就像为另一边的人民工作一样努力。你开始看到一些结果，我们在明尼苏达州看到了。这很难。比如副总统正在倡导
for this child tax credit. We implement it on the state level, lowers childhood poverty. Some of this stuff starts to make sense. And you have to, I'm a school teacher, so I talk Maslow's hierarchy, you know, you can't get to self-actualization about things if people are worried about their safety
这个儿童税收抵免。我们在州一级实施它，降低了儿童贫困率。其中一些事情开始变得有意义。你必须，我是一名学校老师，所以我谈论马斯洛需求层次理论，你知道，如果人们担心他们的安全，你就无法达到自我实现，
and their hunger and things like that. Show people that these policies help make them more money. People are willing to tackle climate change if their lights come on and their bills don't go up. They don't care where the power comes from. In fact, most people would rather see it come from renewables. But I think sometimes we say,
以及他们的饥饿等等。向人们展示这些政策有助于他们赚更多的钱。如果灯亮着，账单没有上涨，人们愿意应对气候变化。他们不在乎电力来自哪里。事实上，大多数人宁愿看到它来自可再生能源。但我认为有时我们说，
well, why can't you see we have to save the planet on this? How about we just create a whole bunch of new union jobs like they did with this proposal, whole bunch of opportunities. That's a great, it's interesting. One of the things that I noticed about you and Vice President Harris is that the way that you guys talk,
嗯，为什么你看不出我们必须拯救地球？我们何不创造一大堆新的工会工作岗位，就像他们在这个提案中所做的那样，一大堆机会。那太棒了，很有趣。我注意到你和哈里斯副总统的一件事是，你们说话的方式，
that sort of antidote you gave by the Vice President talking about we work for all Americans, there is that sense on, that a lot of the people who vote Republican talk about red, blue, blah, blah, blah. You guys don't talk as much about that. You guys talk about all Americans. The divisiveness. Because, yeah, you have to, right?
副总统谈到我们为所有美国人工作时给出的那个轶事，很多投票给共和党的人谈论红、蓝等等。你们谈论这个没那么多。你们谈论的是所有美国人。这种分裂。因为，是的，你必须这样做，对吧？
I mean, we're all here, we all live here, we all, you know. And I think secretly we all want to get along. Of course we do. Yes, I think we all really want to. Human survival. Yeah. I mean, there is a sort of a fun kind of this team, that team sort of, I mean, just speaking to you as a coach,
我的意思是，我们都在这里，我们都住在这里，我们都，你知道。而且我认为私下里我们都想和睦相处。当然我们想。是的，我想我们都真心想。人类生存。是的。我的意思是，有一种这种团队、那种团队的乐趣，我的意思是，作为一名教练和你说话，
and I'm a big sports fan too, like, there's a lot of fun being on one side versus the other, and you kind of watch the scoreboard and then like the standings throughout the year. But that people are bringing this now into politics is literally dangerous at this point. And so like if they could just get a little bit more into their local team and stop being so sort of tribal
我也是一个大体育迷，比如，站在一边而不是另一边有很多乐趣，你会看着记分牌，然后看着全年的排名。但人们现在把这个带入政治在这一点上简直是危险的。所以如果他们能稍微多关注一下他们的本地团队，停止变得如此部落化
and competitive and just think about this unity a little bit more. I'll tell you, Jason, as a, I'm a geographer by training, I love maps except one. Whoever built the red blue map did more damage than you would ever imagine. Because you look at that map and you look at South Dakota and say, oh, South Dakota's all red or whatever.
和竞争性，多思考一下这种团结。我告诉你，杰森，作为一个地理学家，我喜欢地图，除了一个。无论谁制作了红蓝地图，造成的破坏都比你想象的要大。因为你看着那张地图，看着南达科他州说，哦，南达科他州全是红色的，或者其他什么。
That's not true. That is not true. There's a mix. Or even you look at an urban area and say, well, that's blue, everybody in there. That's not true. That is not true. There's a mix. Or even you look at an urban area and say, well, that's blue, everybody in there. That's not true either. And they created this false mindset for us because it's very visual.
那不是真的。那不是真的。有混合。或者即使你看着一个城市地区说，嗯，那是蓝色的，那里面的每个人。那不是真的。那不是真的。有混合。或者即使你看着一个城市地区说，嗯，那是蓝色的，那里面的每个人。那也不是真的。他们为我们制造了这种错误的思维方式，因为它非常直观。
Yeah, it's a good note for the newscasters. They should, instead of having that big map during election time, they should literally split each state into blue and red, just to show the percentages, rather than color at one color. I just want to go on the record as saying, just out of deference to you, Tim, and what you're doing in the office that you're seeking,
是的，这对新闻主播来说是个好建议。他们应该，而不是在选举时放那张大地图，他们应该字面上把每个州分成蓝色和红色，只是为了显示百分比，而不是涂成一种颜色。我只是想记录在案，出于对你，蒂姆，以及你正在寻求的职位的尊重，
that I have withheld a really good joke because it was in really poor taste. We'll get it in the wrap up, Will. I'll do it in the wrap up, but I just wanted you to know that. That's how much respect I have for you. Is it about me? Yes, of course.
我扣留了一个非常好的笑话，因为它品味真的很差。我们会在总结时讲，威尔。我会在总结时讲，但我只是想让你知道。这就是我对你有多尊重。是关于我的吗？是的，当然。
But I could also make it about Jason too. I could, I could. There's plenty there. There's plenty. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know, for me, one of the issues that I want to get to, and sorry if this seems very abrupt,
但我也可以把它变成关于杰森的。我可以，我可以。那里有很多。有很多。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你知道，对我来说，我想解决的问题之一，如果这看起来很突兀，我很抱歉，
but I think the issue for me that needs to be taken head on and we need to talk about, and I can't believe that there's any debate in talking about it considering that it's 2024, is women's healthcare. Yep, yeah, absolutely. For me, it is number one this year. Women's healthcare, and we, the fact that it's even up for debate
但我认为对我来说需要正面解决并需要谈论的问题，而且考虑到现在是2024年，我无法相信在谈论它时还有任何争论，那就是女性医疗保健。是的，是的，绝对。对我来说，这是今年第一位的。女性医疗保健，我们，它甚至被拿来辩论的事实
is absolutely ridiculous. I couldn't agree more. Look, there's household names now of women who should have been able to have their own private healthcare kept to themselves, who are thrust into the national light because they had to go through horrific situations, that should have been as simple as health care being delivered. And look, this is something that's taken a while, and I think for all of us on here, men need to know how to talk about it,
绝对是荒谬的。我完全同意。看，现在有家喻户晓的女性，她们本应能够拥有自己的私人医疗保健并保密，却被推到了全国的聚光灯下，因为她们不得不经历可怕的情况，这本应像提供医疗保健一样简单。看，这是一件需要时间的事情，我认为对于我们这里的所有人来说，男性需要知道如何谈论它，
men need to know how women's bodies work and how doctors understand that. And I think that's something that has changed. I agree with you. I said, while back in the debate, it took a long time for them to get around to two most important issues, the issue of women's bodily autonomy and the democracy. Seems like those would have been two questions
男性需要知道女性的身体是如何运作的，医生是如何理解这一点的。我认为这是已经改变的事情。我同意你。我说，在辩论中，他们花了很长时间才谈到两个最重要的问题，女性身体自主权和民主问题。看起来那应该是两个
to come out of the chute with. What's that great quote or question from Kamala Harris to one of the Supreme Court people about, can you think of a law that does the same for a male body? And it's like, there it is, it's all in that question. It is that simple. And everything stems from that. And these guys are not gonna stop.
一上来就提出的问题。卡玛拉·哈里斯对最高法院某人提出的那个伟大的引语或问题是什么，关于，你能想到一个对男性身体有同样规定的法律吗？就像，它就在那里，一切都在那个问题里。就是那么简单。一切都源于此。而这些人不会停止。
I talk about it, the whole, they're all over us. I don't wanna have to talk with my wife and I infertility issues and trying to use I.U.I. And there isn't a person out there, there isn't a woman out there who's seeking healthcare, who's doing, who wants to talk about it or is in a position who feels good about doing it. Nobody's going out there.
我谈论它，整个，他们无处不在。我不想谈论我和我妻子的不孕不育问题以及尝试使用人工授精。没有一个人，没有一个寻求医疗保健的女性，谁想谈论它，或者处于一个感觉良好的人。没有人会那样做。
That's the other thing is like, you know, abortion right or whatever. Do you think people are, this is something that everybody's looking for? That this is a place that people are in a great place in their life? I'm with you, Will. Who's asking for this agenda?
那是另一件事，比如，你知道，堕胎权或其他什么。你认为人们是，这是每个人都在寻找的东西吗？这是人们生活中处于一个好地方的地方吗？我和你在一起，威尔。谁在要求这个议程？
Yeah, exactly. Who's asking for tax cuts for billionaires? Who's asking to repress women on this? I said this, dude. You think the guy said- A bunch of men. So they go- Rich men. Well, you think they're sitting around in the bar in Wisconsin saying, you know what we really need to do?
是的，完全正确。谁在要求给亿万富翁减税？谁在要求压迫女性？我说了，伙计。你认为那个人说——一群男人。所以他们去——富有的男人。嗯，你认为他们坐在威斯康星州的酒吧里说，你知道我们真正需要做的是什么吗？
We need to ban Orwell's books and we need to give billionaires a tax cut and we need to repress women. Let's hope not. I hope they're talking about we need better jobs. We need to make sure I can't afford to pay for daycare. Tackle these issues. And I think this is what Kamala's putting out.
我们需要禁止奥威尔的书，我们需要给亿万富翁减税，我们需要压迫女性。希望不是。我希望他们在谈论我们需要更好的工作。我们需要确保我负担得起托儿费用。解决这些问题。我认为这就是卡玛拉正在提出的。
Let's really tackle the issues and show them that we're going after these things. But you know when we start to do that, they don't want to talk about it because they got a plan. Listening to them talk about healthcare, listening to Donald Trump ramble about protecting pre-existing conditions, it's terrifying to me if you want to be president of the United States or vice president, you should at least have a working knowledge how insurance works and how healthcare
让我们真正解决这些问题，并向他们展示我们正在追求这些事情。但你知道当我们开始这样做时，他们不想谈论它，因为他们有计划。听他们谈论医疗保健，听唐纳德·特朗普关于保护既有疾病的胡言乱语，这对我来说很可怕，如果你想成为美国总统或副总统，你应该至少具备保险如何运作以及医疗保健如何
works. And they don't. You should have a working knowledge of how anything works. Yeah. It's absurd. If we ever wanted to have a real conversation and you had to remove the word salad and you were like, no, you had, the moment you deviate from the question, you're out,
运作的工作知识。而他们没有。你应该具备任何事物如何运作的工作知识。是的。这很荒谬。如果我们曾经想进行一次真正的对话，而你必须删除那些空话，就像，不，你必须，你偏离问题的瞬间，你就出局了，
it would be- Or that an injection of bleach is just not a real good remedy for anything that ails you. You know, that should be pretty simple. But it is why I have alabaster skin. Listen, I want to ask you something. You know, just as a sidebar, Tim, when you first came on the scene,
那将是——或者注射漂白剂根本不是治疗任何疾病的好方法。你知道，那应该很简单。但这正是我拥有雪白皮肤的原因。听着，我想问你一件事。你知道，作为一个侧面话题，蒂姆，当你刚出现时，
you started talking about that program, you started in Minnesota about free lunches in schools. That blew my mind because my mom raised five kids by herself as the youngest, and I would go to school and I wouldn't have lunch. I just wouldn't eat. We didn't have the money. We didn't have food.
你开始谈论那个你在明尼苏达州开始的关于学校免费午餐的项目。这让我大吃一惊，因为我妈妈独自抚养五个孩子，作为最小的，我会去学校，但我没有午餐。我就是不吃。我们没有钱。我们没有食物。
We're sure made up for it. Pretty hard to learn. You're all caught up, Sean. Pump it. It's just crazy we don't come in and ask them, where's your money for the heat today? We put new windows in the schools, where's your money for the heat today? We put new windows in the schools, where's your money kid?
我们肯定弥补了它。很难学习。你都赶上了，肖恩。加油。我们不进来问他们，你今天的取暖费在哪里，这太疯狂了。我们在学校安装了新窗户，你今天的取暖费在哪里？我们在学校安装了新窗户，孩子，你的钱在哪里？
To have this idea. And look, it's that simple philosophy of investing. Every dollar you invest in early childhood, you get 12 back. Yes, I love that. Where did you get all that growing up? Where did you get this drive to be this servant of like, and by the way, thank you for all your service,
有这个想法。看，这就是投资的简单哲学。你投入到幼儿教育的每一美元，你就能得到12美元的回报。是的，我喜欢那个。你在成长过程中从哪里得到这一切？你从哪里得到这种成为这种仆人的动力，顺便说一句，感谢你所有的服务，
your public service. Well, I think about it and I, you know, when you're older it's a lot of things that come in certainly from parents and small community, but I gotta be honest with you. I grew up Catholic and at that time it was about service and the Catholic nuns, you know, get the little thump in the back of the head
你的公共服务。嗯，我思考它，我，你知道，当你年纪大了，很多事情肯定来自父母和小社区，但我必须对你诚实。我是在天主教环境下长大的，那时它是关于服务的，天主教修女，你知道，在后脑勺轻轻敲一下
thinking you're too big for your own riches. And it really was New Testament to the least amongst this type of stuff. I don't talk about, you don't need people to give you a sermon in elected office, but try and live one a little bit. Try and do something. And I think it was from that.
认为你太自以为是了。这确实是新约中关于对待最弱小者的那种东西。我不谈论，你不需要人们在民选职位上给你布道，但试着稍微活出一点来。试着做点什么。我认为它就是来自那里。
I feel very blessed by that. And it's different now. My wife converted me to Lutheranism, which is basically Catholicism with more singing, but that's about the difference. But it's the same type of principle, so I think that's what it was. And again, we have a saying, we have a great senator who died way too early
我对此感到非常幸运。现在不同了。我妻子让我皈依了路德教，这基本上就是带有更多歌唱的天主教，但这就是区别。但这是同样的原则，所以我认为这就是它。再说一次，我们有一句名言，我们有一位去世太早的伟大参议员
in Paul Wellstone who said, we all do better when we all do better. And it's this sense of servant leadership, this sense of putting back in. And you benefit, and we keep talking about this, this school meals piece of it. You get better achievement, you get better students in school. And so even if you remove the moral we keep talking about this, this school meals piece of it. You get better achievement, you get better students
保罗·威尔斯通，他说，当我们都做得更好时，我们都做得更好。这就是这种仆人式领导的意识，这种回馈的意识。你受益，我们一直在谈论这个，学校餐食的那一部分。你获得更好的成就，你在学校获得更好的学生。所以即使你删除了道德，我们一直在谈论这个，学校餐食的那一部分。你获得更好的成就，你在学校获得更好的学生，
in school, and so even if you remove the moral aspect of feeding a child, you actually save money. So if you're just heartless and don't want to pay higher taxes, you save, you get $12 return on that. So I said the simplification is, you can buy school buses and school meals, or you can buy prison buses and prison meals. You make the decision where you want to invest,
所以即使你删除了喂养孩子的道德层面，你实际上省了钱。所以如果你只是铁石心肠，不想支付更高的税收，你省了，你从那上面得到了12美元的回报。所以我说简化就是，你可以买校车和学校餐食，或者你可以买囚车和监狱餐食。你决定你想在哪里投资，
and it's much better. Yeah, that's great. of course it makes so much sense to invest in the future, to invest in ourselves, to invest in our kids. That's what's gonna help us. Because otherwise if it rots beneath, if that doesn't get supported, then there is no future. That's right.
而且这好得多。是的，那太棒了。当然，投资未来，投资我们自己，投资我们的孩子，这非常有意义。这就是将帮助我们的东西。因为否则如果它在下面腐烂，如果那得不到支持，那么就没有未来。那是对的。
And public schools for all of us are it. This is in rural areas they keep thinking about, these folks who wanna voucherize. So you're gonna have your voucher, so here's your voucher, you get a small tax credit or whatever, but your public school closes. Where are you gonna send them?
而公立学校对我们所有人来说就是一切。这是在农村地区他们一直在想的，这些想要代金券的人。所以你会有你的代金券，所以这是你的代金券，你得到一点税收抵免或其他什么，但你的公立学校关闭了。你要把他们送到哪里？
Where's that in private school when you're out in a town like I was a 400? The idea that the community invested, and I had wonderful public school teachers who were teaching in a small school with 20 kids in a class, coming every day prepared to do that, what a sense of investment they all made.
当你身处像我所在的400人的小镇时，那私立学校在哪里？社区投资的想法，我有很棒的公立学校老师，他们在只有20个孩子的小学校里教书，每天准备好这样做，他们都做出了多么大的投资感。
And I think from that kind of servant leadership, but watching the people around me, the old Mr. Rogers thing, when you need somebody to find the helper, the helpers were all over and they were doing this. There's some of that. I love that. I used to, just talking to you, like Jason said earlier,
我认为来自那种仆人式领导，但看着我周围的人，老罗杰斯先生的那句话，当你需要有人找到帮手时，帮手无处不在，他们正在这样做。有一些那种东西。我喜欢那个。我过去，只是和你交谈，就像杰森刚才说的，
you're just so, I can see you as a teacher. I mean, I didn't have you as a teacher, but you remind me of like, you seem like the greatest teacher ever where all the kids just effing love you. Well, it's a privilege of my life. Now my wife said, I was the fun teacher and she's the teacher that kids came back 10 years later
你就是那么，我能看出你是一名老师。我的意思是，我没有把你当作老师，但你让我想起，你看起来像是有史以来最伟大的老师，所有的孩子都他妈的爱你。嗯，这是我一生的荣幸。现在我妻子说，我是那个有趣的老师，而她是那种孩子10年后回来
and say thank you for teaching me English. And so Mr. Walsh was a barrel of fun, but I learned English. Do you guys have a similar dynamic in parenting? Is she the disciplinarian and you're kind of the fun guy? Yeah, she's amazing. If you've seen her and she can do anything, she is just the quintessential Lutheran Minnesota woman.
说谢谢你教我英语的老师。所以沃尔什先生很有趣，但我学到了英语。你们在育儿方面有类似的动态吗？她是纪律执行者，而你是那个有趣的人？是的，她很棒。如果你见过她，她什么都能做，她就是典型的路德教明尼苏达女性。
Yeah, and she's great. We're partners in this. I feel blessed that we got together. But just to be clear, she was much more political than me early. She would watch the conventions. I'm like, I'm not watching the conventions. It's summer, I'm going golfing or something.
是的，她很棒。我们是这方面的伙伴。我感到幸运我们走到了一起。但要明确一点，她早期比我更政治化。她会看大会。我说，我不看大会。那是夏天，我要去打高尔夫球什么的。
She paid attention. She knew it all. I didn't, she knew who people were. I'm like, I don't know who the senator from North Carolina is. And she would know them all. So Tim, let me ask you this. You're a coach, you're a teacher, but you're a coach. And I love the idea that you're coaching teams and I just think you'd be awesome. It's, you know, we're looking at the clock. It's two we got two minutes left in this election and the team
她很关注。她全都知道。我不知道，她知道人们是谁。我说，我不知道北卡罗来纳州的参议员是谁。而她全都知道。所以蒂姆，让我问你这个。你是一名教练，你是一名老师，但你是一名教练。我喜欢你正在执教团队的想法，我认为你会很棒。你知道，我们在看时钟。还有两分钟，我们在这场选举中还有两分钟，而团队
Which is America's at the sideline. What are you saying? What are you saying to us? What do we need to do to kind of you know? To get a W here for our country. Yeah, I've been I've been given just in the election, but in general for America Look, it's a privilege. I mean, I wish we weren't in this situation. I wish this thing were a blowout It's not gonna be it's gonna come down to the, I wish we weren't in this situation. I wish this thing were a blowout. It's not gonna be. It's gonna come down to the hard work. But the sense of privilege here,
也就是美国在场边。你在说什么？你在对我们说什么？我们需要做什么来，你知道？为我们的国家赢得胜利。是的，我一直在，我一直在给，不仅仅是在选举中，而且是为美国。看，这是一种荣幸。我的意思是，我希望我们没有处于这种境地。我希望这件事是一场压倒性的胜利。它不会是，它将归结为，我希望我们没有处于这种境地。我希望这件事是一场压倒性的胜利。它不会是。它将归结为艰苦的工作。但这里的特权感，
this isn't about the next four years. This is about the next 40. And you're hearing from your people you know around the world. The rest of the world's looking for us to do the right thing here. And I think to be a part of that and everybody to be the little things they can do,
这不是关于未来四年。这是关于未来40年。你从你认识的世界各地的人那里听到。世界其他地方正在期待我们在这里做正确的事情。我认为成为其中的一部分，每个人都做他们能做的点点滴滴，
whether it's door knocking, whether it's going on and giving what little they have, donations that people give, 10 bucks, that's a lot for a lot of people. They do something else and they give the help. I think it's this idea that you can be part of something bigger and that's what people want. That's the whole thing about teams.
无论是敲门，还是去捐出他们仅有的一点东西，人们给的捐款，10块钱，这对很多人来说很多。他们做别的事情，他们提供帮助。我认为这就是你可以成为更宏大事物一部分的想法，而这正是人们想要的。这就是团队的全部意义。
Like the kids who enjoyed being on football teams were the most, is the kid who got in on kickoffs because you're going to play everybody. He wasn't the best athlete maybe, but that kid was there because he was with his buddies. He was with his team. And I think for Americans, this idea we can be in this, we don't have to agree, and I'm not naive.
比如那些喜欢参加橄榄球队的孩子是最，是那个在开球时上场的孩子，因为你要和每个人一起玩。他可能不是最好的运动员，但那个孩子在那里是因为他和他的伙伴在一起。他和他的团队在一起。我认为对于美国人来说，这个想法我们可以参与其中，我们不必同意，我并不天真。
This is tough. There's folks that don't agree on anything. But I think the vast majority of people realize it doesn't need to be this way. And I give Kamala Harris full credit. This idea of joy, and I watched the Wall Street Journal poo poo joy. I'll take joy over being like crabby and awful and no one wants to be around you. That's what she's doing and politics can be that way.
这很难。有些人什么都不赞同。但我认为绝大多数人意识到不需要这样。我给卡玛拉·哈里斯充分的赞誉。这种快乐的理念，我看着《华尔街日报》对快乐嗤之以鼻。我宁愿选择快乐，而不是像个脾气暴躁、糟糕透顶、没人想和你在一起的人。这就是她正在做的，政治可以是那样的。
Look, Donald Trump wants to make it, it would be easier I guess he's saying is just elect one person forever and let them make the decisions. This democracy stuff is hard, it's messy, it's difficult and it's frustrating, but it's the best that's been devised. Yeah, and it's the best path towards community.
看，唐纳德·特朗普想让它，我想他是在说，只要永远选一个人，让他们做决定会更容易。这些民主的东西很难，很乱，很困难，而且很令人沮丧，但它是设计出来的最好的。是的，这是通往社区的最佳途径。
And we'll let you go, but I wanna ask you, sort of building on that notion of community and everybody coming together, and after you guys win, what do you think might possibly be a big give that you and Kamala could possibly offer to the folks who didn't vote for you guys, that we get them so happy or so comfortable that they would feel good about uniting
我们要让你走了，但我问你，在某种程度上建立在社区和每个人团结在一起的概念上，在你们获胜后，你认为你和卡玛拉可能给那些没有投票给你们的人提供什么大的礼物，让我们让他们如此快乐或如此舒适，以至于他们会觉得团结起来很好
with the rest of the country, getting back to a bit more. Other than they'll get more jobs and they'll save for life. Right, but that notion of kind of becoming one big happy family and like not just the standard speech about, you know, I want to be president for all of that, but something maybe taken directly
与国家其他部分一起，回到更多一点。除了他们会得到更多工作，他们会为生活储蓄。对，但那种成为一个幸福大家庭的概念，不仅仅是关于，你知道，我想成为所有人的总统的标准演讲，而是可能直接取自
from the Republican platform or their agenda that would be felt as that give or that offer that would come across and have the effectiveness of like an olive branch. Thought about that. Well, she said it and I agree with her. She needs to appoint a Republican to the cabinet. I do think it matters to her, to a position of authority.
共和党纲领或他们的议程的东西，会被视为那种礼物或提议，会像橄榄枝一样有效。想过那个。嗯，她说了，我同意她。她需要任命一名共和党人进入内阁。我确实认为这对她很重要，到一个权威职位。
And look, there's a lot of them out there. These folks who are coming out and speaking on behalf of these Republicans, I disagree with many of them. Their values are there. I served with these people. People like Jeff Flake, the Senator from Arizona, super conservative, but that man is as honest as anything.
看，外面有很多这样的人。这些站出来代表这些共和党人说话的人，我不同意他们中的许多人。他们的价值观在那里。我和这些人一起服务过。像杰夫·弗莱克，亚利桑那州的参议员，超级保守，但那个人非常诚实。
I've dealt with him. Jim Langford, who wrote the big piece of the immigration bill. I served with him. That guy is the most conservative person I ever met, but he's big piece of the immigration bill. That they killed, yeah. I served with him. That guy is the most conservative person I ever met, but he's also one of the most honorable. Some of these people need to be put in a position
我和他打过交道。吉姆·兰福德，他写了移民法案的大部分内容。我和他一起服务过。那家伙是我见过最保守的人，但他也是移民法案的大部分内容。他们杀死了那个，是的。我和他一起服务过。那家伙是我见过最保守的人，但他也是最光荣的人之一。这些人中的一些人需要被放在一个位置
where they truly have the ability to influence things. That's awesome. Because they are ethical and they care about this country. And I think that's something that really sets her apart to make a high profile appointment to the county. Or two, or three. Yes, bring them, folks who care about the country. And let us, look, I don't want to be surrounded by people.
他们真正有能力影响事情。那太棒了。因为他们有道德，他们关心这个国家。我认为这是真正让她与众不同的地方，向内阁进行高调任命。或者两个，或者三个。是的，带上他们，关心国家的人。让我们，看，我不想被人们包围。
In my organization, my folks know that I'll say something. They say, you know, with all due respect, governor, that is a horrible idea and we should not do it. And I'm like, okay, good, thank you for stopping me from doing that horrible idea. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think I need to know this. Like giving away SUVs with every tractor.
在我的组织里，我的伙伴们知道我会说些什么。他们说，恕我直言，州长，那是个可怕的主意，我们不应该那样做。我说，好的，谢谢你阻止我做那个可怕的主意。是的，是的，是的。我想我需要知道这个。比如给每台拖拉机送SUV。
That was a horrible idea. I need to know before you leave what kind of snacks are on the plane or the car or the truck. What settles you? Yeah, this just irritates, and I don't do it to irritate my pescatarian daughter. A beef jerky is my thing. Sure.
那是个可怕的主意。在你离开之前，我需要知道飞机、汽车或卡车上有什么零食。什么能让你平静下来？是的，这只是激怒，我这样做不是为了激怒我那吃鱼素的女儿。牛肉干是我的最爱。当然。
I'm a homemade beef jerky, and Pete Buttigieg's in-laws made some and he brought me some. And I like the idea of a friend bringing you homemade beef jerky and know that that pleases you more than anything. So that's my thing. All right, well, listen, we just can't thank you enough for the trust to sit with us and your time.
我是自制牛肉干，皮特·布蒂吉格的姻亲做了一些，他带给我一些。我喜欢朋友带给你自制牛肉干的想法，并且知道这比什么都让你高兴。所以那是我的东西。好吧，听着，我们无法感谢你对我们的信任以及你的时间。
We're such big fans and we wish you the best of luck and safety out there on the trail. And bring us that W. We're gonna do everything we can and just couldn't be more thrilled that you're a part of this. Thank all three of you. We are really honored and your authentic self
我们是如此大的粉丝，我们祝你在竞选路上好运和安全。并给我们带来那个胜利。我们会尽我们所能，只是对你是其中的一部分感到无比激动。感谢你们三位。我们真的很荣幸，你的真实自我
just shines through and that authenticity is just so refreshing and great. Yeah, this was big deal for me, you guys. Thank you for having me on. I'm a big fan and appreciate all you're doing. Yeah, I like it. We really appreciate it. Thank you, Tim.
只是闪耀着光芒，那种真实性是如此令人耳目一新和伟大。是的，这对我很重要，你们。谢谢你们邀请我。我是个大粉丝，感谢你们所做的一切。是的，我喜欢它。我们真的很感激。谢谢你，蒂姆。
Thanks, guys. Bye, yeah. Have a great day. That was great, thank you. You guys are the best. Hey, I didn't get in on this. I heard you guys often when you're talking, you're talking the golf stuff. This is a thing, honest to God,
谢谢，伙计们。再见，是的。祝你有美好的一天。那太棒了，谢谢。你们是最棒的。嘿，我没参与这个。我经常听到你们谈话时，你们在谈论高尔夫的东西。这是一件事，上帝作证，
I don't know if you know this. So I grew up in that really small town. Yeah. Sand green golf, three bucks green feed. You know it? I know about it. What is sand green golf? Oh, you gotta hear this.
我不知道你是否知道这个。所以我是在那个非常小的镇上长大的。是的。沙地果岭高尔夫，三块钱果岭费。你知道吗？我知道它。什么是沙地果岭高尔夫？哦，你一定要听这个。
This is so exciting. So set it up again so people know. So you grew up in Nebraska. I did, small town. And you played golf there. Played golf, and like everybody played golf, farmers, everybody, and it wasn't country club golf, it was sand green golf.
这太令人兴奋了。所以再设置一下，让人们知道。所以你是在内布拉斯加州长大的。是的，小镇。你在那里打高尔夫。打高尔夫，就像每个人都打高尔夫，农民，每个人，那不是乡村俱乐部高尔夫，那是沙地果岭高尔夫。
And what it is is the greens are made out of sand and they're oiled with vegetable oil. Well in the old days they were oiled with oil, which was not good. I think this is what they do in the Middle East. In Australia. You rake the green with a path and then you putt and then you rake it again to put ridges in it.
它是什么，果岭是用沙子做的，它们用植物油上油。嗯，在过去的日子里，它们用油上油，那不好。我想这就是他们在在中东做的事情。在澳大利亚。你用路径耙果岭，然后你推杆，然后你再次耙它以在上面放脊。
And they're little like postage stamp sized greens, but it's a whole different game. But I hear you guys talk a lot about golf. You've got to get on a sand green golf course. Listen, listen, once you've won and you want to take a little break, Jason and I will meet you in Nebraska. Let's go play some sand green golf.
它们是像邮票大小的果岭，但这完全是不同的游戏。但我听到你们谈论很多关于高尔夫。你们必须去沙地果岭高尔夫球场。听着，听着，一旦你赢了，你想休息一下，杰森和我会在内布拉斯加州见你。让我们去打一些沙地果岭高尔夫。
I'm working even harder now. We gotta work. Okay, okay. We're gonna find ya. All right, thanks fellas. Thanks, man. Thank you, sir. Let's get her done.
我现在工作更努力了。我们得工作。好的，好的。我们会找到你的。好吧，谢谢伙计们。谢谢，伙计。谢谢你，先生。让我们完成它。
Yeah, absolutely. Bye, Tim. Thank you, pal. Boy, that fella, I mean, he, Really cool. He gives politicians a good name, in my opinion. Yes, in my opinion as well. I'm with you.
是的，绝对。再见，蒂姆。谢谢你，伙计。天哪，那个家伙，我的意思是，他，真的很酷。在我看来，他给了政客一个好名声。是的，在我看来也是。我和你在一起。
You immediately, he's the dad I always wanna. And I know that there are a lot of people out there who don't want, and I, so I get you saying in my opinion, but the one thing you can't knock is the guy's authenticity. Yeah. He's just such an authentic, real person and it's great talking to him. How can you not like that guy?
你立刻，他是我一直想要的爸爸。我知道外面有很多人不想要，而且我，所以我明白你说在我看来，但你不能否认的是这个家伙的真实性。是的。他只是一个如此真实、真实的人，和他交谈很棒。你怎么能不喜欢那个家伙？
I'm sure you can disagree with some of his policies, I'm sure, but I'm so excited about the prospect of simply just having somebody represent me and the country I love, that I'm not sort of worrying about them saying something mean, nasty, offensive. I just, he's just like a guy I like to call my representative. I'm just, I would be proud of that. And also not a guy who's out there to enrich himself
我相信你可以不同意他的一些政策，我相信，但我对仅仅拥有一个代表我和我所爱的国家的人的前景感到如此兴奋，以至于我不会担心他们说一些刻薄、肮脏、冒犯的话。我只是，他就像一个我想称之为我的代表的家伙。我只是，我会为此感到自豪。而且也不是一个为了充实自己
or protect himself and use the office as a way to avoid prosecution. Right? Yeah, I mean, truly, truly. It's just so not self-serving, it's the opposite. It's public service, right? Yeah, the truth. And he's so, yeah, it's pretty,
或保护自己并利用职位作为避免起诉的方式的家伙。对吧？是的，我的意思是，真的，真的。这太不自私了，恰恰相反。这是公共服务，对吧？是的，真相。而且他如此，是的，这很，
I think the most jarring thing was seeing Mike Terry there at the end, who works with us, our producers, that he was actually in the room. Yeah, that he was there with Tim Waldo. Yeah, interesting, very interesting. But I like him a lot. Did you guys have any questions that you didn't get to that you wanted to?
我认为最刺耳的事情是看到迈克·特里在那里，他与我们合作，我们的制片人，他实际上在房间里。是的，他和蒂姆·沃尔兹在那里。是的，有趣，非常有趣。但我很喜欢他。你们有什么没来得及问的问题吗？
I wanted to mention this thing that there have been some fake fundraising emails that were going out. This is true. Oh, yeah. Yes. That he was gonna be asking about. But we get these fake ones that are coming from them and they wanted to address them
我想提到这件事，有一些虚假的筹款电子邮件发出。这是真的。哦，是的。是的。他会问的。但我们收到这些来自他们的虚假邮件，他们想解决它们
and I think they're working on it. Oh really? Yeah. It's gonna be hard to track. I wanna know like. There's a lot of awful people out there. I wanna know what like bad TV shows he watches. I wanted to know like if he has like a little game on his phone that when he has a little game on his phone
而且我认为他们正在努力解决。哦，真的吗？是的。这很难追踪。我想知道像。外面有很多糟糕的人。我想知道他看什么糟糕的电视节目。我想知道他是否像手机里有一个小游戏，当他有一个小游戏在手机里
that when he has a little quiet moment, like we do with like Wordle or something, I bet he's got something fun in there. Something really silly. Candy Crush is it? Yeah, he's got a pretty full plate these days. I know, but you've got to like, two minutes to like.
当他有一个安静的时刻，就像我们用Wordle或其他什么一样，我打赌他那里有有趣的东西。一些非常愚蠢的东西。糖果粉碎传奇？是的，他这些天很忙。我知道，但你必须，两分钟到像。
You have to be able to, yeah, exactly. Even if it's just like going into the bathroom and like just sitting down, you know, like not even like taking your pants down, but just like hiding in a stall somewhere just to get some quiet. Yeah, yeah. Right, right, I know.
你必须能够，是的，完全正确。即使只是像走进浴室，就像坐下来，你知道，甚至不像脱下裤子，只是像躲在某个隔间里，只是为了得到一些安静。是的，是的。对，对，我知道。
Oh, I know how he feels. Oh, I can't go anywhere. I know it, sweetheart. Oh, but isn't that a good idea though, you guys, to do, to you know, Fox, CNN, it doesn't matter who you are, to split, instead of showing a map of this is all red, this is all blue state, just cut it in half
哦，我明白他的感受。哦，我哪儿也去不了。亲爱的，我懂。哦，但你们不觉得这是个好主意吗？不管是福克斯新闻还是CNN，不管你是谁，与其展示一张全红或全蓝的州地图，不如把它一分为二，
and show us the percentages of each. Well, they do actually. Oh yes. The great Steve Kornacki will go in there and he will zoom in and it will expand and you will see sort of the micro of each of these districts and states and you will see how it is sort of split up inside there. All right, fine.
然后向我们展示各自的百分比。嗯，他们其实是这么做的。哦，是的。伟大的史蒂夫·科纳基会进去，他会放大，它会展开，你会看到这些选区和州内部的微观情况，你会看到它们在内部是如何划分的。好吧，行吧。
Yeah, it's true. Also, those maps are so deceiving because when you look at, when you put it up against population, Yeah, it's always different. Where population is centered. Ah, it's the electoral college. What are you gonna do?
是的，确实如此。而且，这些地图太具有欺骗性了，因为当你把它和人口放在一起看时，是的，情况总是不同的。人口集中的地方。啊，这就是选举人团制度。你能怎么办呢？
How are we gonna get centered on the electoral college. So what are you gonna do? Yeah, yeah. How are we gonna get rid of that electoral college? Yeah, we can't do it here from our stupid ass podcast. You know, we need smart folks. I know, I know. We can't. And they're a button. And we're on our way, hopefully.
我们该如何解决选举人团的问题呢？所以你打算怎么办？是啊，是啊。我们该如何废除那个选举人团制度呢？是的，我们在这个愚蠢的播客里做不到。你知道，我们需要聪明人。我知道，我知道。我们做不到。他们就在按钮上。希望我们正在路上。
You know what I wanna say to the electoral college? Uh oh, here it comes, Willie. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Bye! Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道我想对选举人团说什么吗？哦，来了，威利。再见。再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。再见！罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。